hello pollination my name is having
coverage of my laundry believe and I
believe that monstrance will solve all
of the world's major problems
so the puzzle of your journey today I'm
going to talk about seven ways to
improve for people so I often get asked
entrepreneur how are you my people still
Devin I need health either with my
customers even when I'm marketing going
out the trade shows or meeting people or
with my team how we both either how do I
prove my people skills and so I thought
I think this video sharing seven
different ways I think wow you in your
chest so tip number one is to decide
what you want to improve there's a lot
of different things around people skills
and if you want to improve it all of
them it can be a challenge you mean eyes
wants it so having focused gives you
clarity and allows you to really improve
so the next you want to improve your
networking skills you want improve the
leadership skills you want to improve
your social setting skills you know what
is it exactly that one group you can
figure that out and just focus for the
one most important sit like maybe you
just want to be a better leader but you
don't really care that much about
networking or maybe you don't have a
genius you don't carry leadership skills
maybe all you want to do is get more
sales or you're going to event one
learns how to shake hands and make a
connection with people and figure out
exactly what it is if you want to learn
if you can get that focus and clarity
it's much more easy to make rapid
progress achieve so there is a lot of
success this is always a go-to for me if
you don't know what they're doing if
you're trying to learn something one of
the fastest way to do this find someone
who's already done it and learn from
them instead of you struggling and
trying to figure it out learn from
someone who's already gone out and done
it it automatically shortcut your path
to success and you may not even figure
it out most of the things that you're
trying until you get that input from
someone else and so again how can it
clarity I want to be a master
great who is a master that for curve in
your eyes voting you to look at
different videos you can read different
books we do attend conferences right
like by the master networker or I don't
care one picture religious break who are
the leadership experts how can it hang
around them how can I be with them as
much as possible going to their events
reading their books being around them
watching the videos and I would highly
encourage you not just as three times
it's not just to look at the how-to
because everybody will have here is s
here the seven ways to do I'm very good
about how their business what does it
feel to see how they doing right so if
I'm making a video of how to write a lot
right don't just watch the video how to
write the book watch me document the
process I mean I don't know how many
videos I mean to work through videos
documenting the process watch that or
what somebody else going to the process
having that many videos is great it's a
starting point but a lot of the content
is also going to come by just watching
them so just reading an article about
how to make an introduction to somebody
versus watching somebody who's really
good at it doing this and demoing it and
showing it and guide other people to it
you'll learn a lot more through that
process than just by reading article and
so when you clearly identify by concept
Lawrence they did it for what it is that
you want to work on then go over model
success find the person's the genius at
it and try to be around them go to their
events see them do in line watch their
videos and get their books and read
their content but I want you to see it
and feel it because when you can feel an
emotional level and not just understand
it up here you much unlikely to retain
it take action does it recruit practice
practice practice like anything else you
want to get better at ulta genetic
factors the identity times would
consistently every day the practice to
get better compute so we've identified
what is what people doesn't want to work
on we model the test
the best people in the world is doing it
pretend some of their events and watch
the videos in president club
great sessions knowledge like it's not
going to actually happen please do
something about it
you can understand how to do a jump on a
snowboard but you're not going to get
the muscle memory after you've the
performance review practice and you can
call the ball the ball the ball and get
better the practice and so whatever it
is you want to move on you got to put in
the rest I've made 512 IDEO under-seat
you can write a thousand of them are not
even public so a thousand videos which
is more than most people do in general a
YouTube channel then another example
I'm just probably on board my team is
watched unlocking ability series and
right now Phil is our visual yeah when
she doesn't unlock easily video her
first video took over a hundred tapes
each time to get that best version that
she'll spend every every Friday the
whole day building building building
building building hundreds of tastes and
if you watch her first video she with a
free video refers to the second to the
third you'll see that she's done maybe
better in this one but she put in the
work as home filling up her schedule I'm
giving her interviews and giving her
coaching sessions I'm giving her
entrepreneurs to talk to I've given her
opportunities to speak options being the
video she heard scheduled just rammed
full right she came here and she did two
videos with me today is filming day and
she just me back from a coaching college
interview that she had the rush back to
do more coaching calls were interviewed
the whole day is full because she's
putting on the rest it she's really good
now but to get great tickets where she
wants to be to build a million dollar
business around 15 Okocha she wants to
do is I'm here to help her with she's
got a footing the repetition to get
better and so whatever you learn
whatever that thing is it can pull from
that expertise you want to learn just
put into practice and finding somebody
to work so if it's networking races once
the still does go off practice like what
a one networking event a mom's is not
going to
because multiple events for reading
practice networking on the subway like
every day you want a motive to kill to
practice if it's about report building
if you learn about how to match in here
so the learning is matching body
language writing something like this and
kind of cool like this right if somebody
I'm crossing you circle your arms
crossed and you try to lead them because
of the other arms open and you know that
establish some rapport right master
hearing great practice that practices
with your intimate packages with your
friends right
even without telling them you this
package thing and sometimes even a fail
especially this being a signal suck a
lot of the methods won't work
why did you expect them to because
you're just starting out and you suck
expect that to happen and you get better
if you practice practice practice
practice better because you have the
knowledge you know what you're supposed
to do you can actually do it yes get it
by putting the work doing the practice
and go to we got it we're in awesome
misfit nation has just taken over seven
ways hi everyone my name is Dave Lucas
on the host of the misfit entrepreneur
podcast and we are tackling number four
in seven ways in people skills this week
the answer I have for you is actually a
two-part answer and the first part is
actually something that I learned from a
mentor of mine that ran a fortune 100
company and I learned it many years ago
and it goes like this if you want to
know what john smith buys you have to
see things through john smith's eyes and
what that means is that you really need
to put yourself in the other person's
shoes you really need to understand what
motivates them what drives them what
they care about what the levers are that
really drive their decisions and why
they do things once you understand that
nursing what they want out of something
then it makes it that much easier to get
what you want or be able to get the
outcome that you're looking for whether
you're negotiating a deal putting
together a big project or just want to
work better with somebody the second
part of this actually is the concept
made famous by Zig Ziglar and that goes
like this if you help somebody get what
they want you'll get what you want and
more and really it's the law of
reciprocity so the more that you are
focused on helping others get what they
want and accomplish
things they want you'll be amazed at
what it does for you to come back to you
tenfold so when you pair those two
together really understanding what
drives someone motivates them and then
looking for the best way to help them
get there and make it mutually
beneficial
everybody wins and that's the important
thing so that's number four in seven
ways this week hope you can take that
and put it to work in your life right
now and make a big difference
thank you tip number five is five lesson
you're curious about the easiest
conversation of how the confident
easiest way to connect with somebody
else it is through some kind of joint
love right so if you can find consummate
who are genuinely curious about them in
its weight if you have a conversation we
need you to get to know them so prevents
it for me anything around
entrepreneurship I am generally good I
love to talk to you right if I find out
if you're an entrepreneur we are going
to have an amazing discussion it's just
going to happen you will immediately
perk up my my excitement and I'm going
to want to challenge you talk to you
understand you see how I can help you
you can clearly have five minutes
together I want to be able to provide
value and get you on your path it's just
it's just who I am and so try to find
some kind of common ground between you
and the other person will really help
now you can do you know in advance
anything about that person you're going
to stop them on Twitter and Instagram
and Facebook and YouTube and just kind
of understand it and good about them
what to meet each student and you want
to lead with hey I saw that you love
horror shooters on Twitter that's
awesome tell me about horseshoes because
if you don't have to get abortion
disconnects and it's kind of creepy
soccer scariest you don't want to let
them know you've been following them
along on Twitter but it advises them is
genuine Houston that's the key right and
so you can start if you don't anything
about them you could start in the event
how do they come to suspect you're both
at this event what what is it that comes
or how do they know the holes how did
they find this places a searcher it
online over the reasons for coming here
you know that opens up a discussion and
it is looking for ways to genuinely be
curious about the other person you can
find any kind of genuine connection
there then it's easy to get to the top
of themselves and it's easy to a phone
number for this number assistance
understand their walk people love
talking about themselves and I love
getting people excited but when I'm
talking on Twitter
I like understanding why they serve
their business because I want to get
them thumbs up if you are talking about
something that is meaningful to you that
on a deep emotional level gets you
feeling excited like this is your
purpose then it's so much easier to
follow through on a conversation I'm
talking too much when I ask them why the
terms of business and they tell me the
story about deep meaningful connection
to this product they're making a service
or maybe they started because of a
parent or whatever that backstory is
there has to be something there that
fuel them to want to do this thing and
whether it shows this event or choose a
career path or marry that person
whatever it is I think you understand
their lie and get them excited about it
it's much when you do to form a bond of
affection when people ask me my life and
they genuinely care about if you have to
actually care into success so why uses
like with change Europe and why why do
you do this thing is awesome
right you'll just if you haven't got to
get me being excited did you get me
telling an excited story like I am now
then I'm much more like this amendment
watching like this to one of the
business be much more likely to want to
refer you it what you like to take
whatever actually they want you to take
even if it's just get to know each other
exchange contact information whatever it
is if you can get somebody to explain
their why on an emotional level because
it's genuine and care about it as much
we need to build rapport and since
number seven is help them with their
goals and this builds off of what days
I'm missing
were saying what kind of custom
accomplish what it is is the China
College I like to stay eternal my team
is the most dangerous thing that you can
do is tell me what your goal is as soon
as I know what your goal is that your
dream is now it's on my radar and I'm
going to try to make it happen for you
and I'm going to push you to go up and
do it and when you say that you can't do
because of X Y Z or whatever limiting
beliefs you have we're pushing for those
things baby it's going to have and so I
heard United everybody I mean just it's
not even strategies just natural just
what I try to do why I don't even think
about it but now that we're kind of
making a list of seven things to do it's
one of us it can be highly highly highly
effective when it was a climate on
recently it was an event for youtubers
one of my main things was every time I
met somebody I tried to introduce tons
of somebody else that could help so
there was Sean's video influencers who
was trying to interview youtubers I
asked how many we had set up with which
people wouldn't try to cop the show many
people who tried to be buggy here he has
this target like well how many be done
so far names here's great if I find
somebody that's relevant so we need to
do yes that's the other thing is awesome
so every time I made an entrepreneur
youtuber who has certain channel size
that sum up be a zip for Sean's channel
they watched Sean's videos I'm going
tell about how did you do and Sean is
happy and the other entrepreneur attack
because they're getting exposure
I'm happy that he was able to make that
connection was to the point where
Charlie from charisma on command is one
of the channels that I love watching
I meant halex eMERCOM I use it to the
Sean he's going to be a Jackman video
newsletters Charlie than with the his
challenge made a video about how to
network as initiative which was being
video increasing felt me and my
strategies at fibercon and how amazing
he was all the connections of is amazing
by it's not really knowing a lot of
people and a lot of us just based on
this it's not that I'm some genius it's
just I meet somebody I understand their
why I ask questions about them and try
to figure what their goal is not so much
your teaching point of view is just how
I how I think and then I just keep that
in my head this bird's to accomplish
this I mean
we on the car you guys myself you know
Jill Charlie hirachand you know this guy
I just trying to make those natural
connection but just something that I
think if you do it if you try to help
other people with their goal it's all
over the comeback you may not be in a
way that you recognize or that is
immediate but it comes back number 50
example on my trip to LA us alone what
took my my tes team system to neurotic
in LA and I see pack extra day to do me
I had an even Frank Ranger the legendary
Hollywood producer his assistant reached
up to me and Brian wanted to meet with
me or one-on-one I member Lewis house
later on that afternoon from school
breakfast and I were going to GT channel
we there you guys to check out it's
pretty fun and then I have another
couple media tip advantage and then I
came back two weeks ago watching me lose
his channel with Wyclef Jean and Mike
left and the Fugees was talking about
Brian region and saying disguise one of
the top guys in Hollywood history and
someone who you need to have out the
show and listen see how that sounds
really interesting
I wrote the Louis's a Louis I saw Mike
slept on your show you mean Jeff Ryan
great series but interested I should
miss Ryan a couple hours before I met
you when I was LA I can set up into if
you want the team making where that goes
this abducted me to thank you so much
and so I use
Louisa to Brian's assistant and maybe
something happened maybe something
nothing that you know maybe maybe
doesn't work out maybe just become more
vitamins to know the changes either
going to connect tilt is going to work
out and both Lewis and Brian will be
grateful that's I would want to meet
that connection now I'm not using sports
it's not like hey Louis I am i tribute
applying so now you want me this for my
blog or my whatever not really how it
works I really will keep these scores
but but what it just feels good to help
people and to if you help people and
with consistent then it comes back to
you it just always does
and so when you're talking people
understand what their main goals are
what is it try to accomplish whether it
means I don't think how can I help
I mean the introduction it made me and
maybe just giving them a push you know
beyond their limitation
mages equally with another may just be
checking in and seeing how they're doing
finding ways to help them comfortable
because huge huge difference so most of
my success away is my how to prove your
people skills I made this video because
a merman will not ask you to so there's
a topic you'd like me to cover in a
future 7 week videos check out the link
in description and go and cast your
golem who you're gonna win and you'll
see some content coming soon I don't
know what did you think this video what
was your favorite chips which is going
to really apply somehow to life or to
your business is there anything that you
want to add the list that I missed leave
in the comments below I'm really curious
to see what you guys I also want to give
a quick shout-out to disease Lucas from
the misfit entrepreneur Dave thank you
so much for being in this video as well
as posting the picture of my book while
you're on the beach I really appreciate
this department and I'm so glad you
enjoy the read so thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you need to
believe in yourself and whatever three
one where it is much love